[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the first
podcast on our mother's chest channel
the podcast doesn't yet have a name
since this is the first one and well
regarding if I will continue doing this
if you guys will enjoy it if we at this
time Maxime and I are going to enjoy it
I'm gonna decide whether or not to
continue with with the podcasts but I'm
very excited about this and I hope you
guys will enjoy it so the guest for the
first podcast is none other than Maxime
for Sheila gravely Maxime hello everyone
thank you thanks for that so you don't
really need an introduction in the chess
world but I'm hoping more and more
people will be joining our chess
community and that well yeah I I do want
everyone to feel welcome so basically in
short you are currently world number 5
on the and ello world rating list you
are number 2 I believe in rapid and
number 3 in blitz yeah yeah but also
you've pretty much topped everything
last year after your performance in
Grantchester you were ranked number 1 in
both rapid and blitz and in 2016 you
notice yeah and in 2016 in August you've
been ranked number 2 in the world so
basically if that's everything other
than that elusive classical number one
spot which magazine the only one was not
manage that yes yeah so now that we're
in this situation due to the coronavirus
the logged on and everything we've seen
really like a boom in online chess and
you've been well fairly busy
you had the Magnus Invitational you had
the Nations Cup you've had the log down
simultaneous exhibition on leeches so
one thing that I myself and a lot of
people have been wondering is it is it
only it does only appear that way or are
there more blunders in online chess than
over the board
yes I was actually not expecting this
months to be so busy but it turns out
that a lot of major websites and feet
they also make some plans so when I
first organized this online Simon I
thought - the good way for for people to
to spend some free time but it turned
out that that was not so much free time
after all but it was a fun experience
and as for Brent there's clearly I think
yes I think maybe not for everyone but
for a lot of persons playing especially
at elite level well you know we have
competitiveness only in terms of over
support play it's more difficult for us
to adjust to playing online no there are
real stakes to it but at the same time
we're not used to spending time online
basically I mean I was only playing in
strippers or one crossover booth at
games basically online and now we're
playing like 15 plus 10 25 plus 10 and
that's like for Internet it's very
suburban control so it's very difficult
to adjust and to spend your time
properly like you would do over the
boards also I think two more things
explained blunders first of all we are
playing on a two dimensional chess board
instead of you know a natural chess
board and the you know visual visual
presentation you get is different and
it's easier to miss some connections
that you will find easily on the chess
boards and online you just kind of of
miss it and the last thing and maybe the
most important one is clicking on the
mouse and making a move is much less
responsibilities and actually touching a
base moving it and placing
the clock so that's and when you have
less responsibility or at least you feel
like it you you're less careful and it
goes against all so you're saying that
your ability to recognize patterns is
different in a 3d environment than in a
2d chessboard yes I mean that's clear
even from just preparation so when we
were preparing visual is visualizing
lines on the computer so we were making
some moves and we get to let's say the
critical position and they will make a
decision we're ready to play it or not
and when you see it sometimes you know
you'll stop the computer that I knew is
there's no problem so you just saying
find this position is fine
so let's go play it and then you you
come to support and now you're sitting
in front of the board and you have your
position and then you start noticing
ideas for white let's I mean if you're
black let's say you start noticing ideas
for white and you start to feel a bit
uncomfortable you see there was this
ideas it's our idea that I'm and may be
underestimated
and again it's because responsibility
when you were at the chess board and
every move is important and every if we
moment you like attention it could cost
you the game makes you feel more burden
at the chessboard sannan-san it does on
the computer at your arm
of course it's it's very different like
maybe it would be different for instance
if we play online at but on a physical
location so like we're facing each other
and we were moving the mouse but you can
see your opponent
maybe there's also a touch movement race
so like if you click on the mouse you
cannot take back you have to move that
pace and so on that'd be interesting not
know pre moving
yeah but then it does it go the other
way around are perhaps younger players
who have been playing a lot more online
than over the board and maybe pattern
recognition works the other way around
for them maybe they're struggling a bit
more over the board it's very possible
that if you've played online or your
life then suddenly the switch to the
actual chess what is different it's not
that we've not been playing online I
mean we're I mean the first online
innovation and I mean I've played tens
of thousands of games of who leads but
they weigh much less than an actual
competitive game that you're playing
from your home and your computer and
yeah you I mean at least I can speak on
me for myself but I it feels
competitiveness bit less and I think
that's also the case for four out of of
the players the other players but since
you already mentioned bullet when you
play bullet to do you use your top
preparation or do you play funky moves
like anything goes I like to play
something move something oh yeah oh yeah
no I mean sometimes it happens up online
people play some preparation I mean even
in you know good at games or big game
sucks where there's not much at stake
but but yeah I would generally just play
funky lines and and if I want to test up
with weapons away probably log in
anonymously and play with okay
and regarding online raiding like I said
you've been number one in blitz you'd be
number one in rapid number two in
classical does it does it bother you
when you lose rating online even though
it's not actual rating at the moment no
but of course if there's like no
official online waiting with
you know the competitive games we play
it might be a different story but for
now yeah if I'm not top things on the
list for a bullet or whatever I really I
really don't care but but at the moment
you know I mean because of course Magnus
announced also that is launching this
tour so you know official tournaments
over the Internet are gonna take big
progression at leasts and there's a long
time situation where we are in purely
the idea would be to take to take it
seriously but not in terms of waiting of
course in terms of avoiding losses and
winning some games winning trying to
enter tournament and so on okay so since
you already mentioned the Magnus
Invitational you took part and not so
long ago what were your thoughts on on
playing it on having four games every
day was it was it exhausting I mean how
was the overall experience now not so
much regarding your result but just the
play yeah I thought it was interesting I
thought and I think the plan is to
adjust it I've thought knockout question
was too little like you have almost two
weeks of preliminary play and then only
two days of semifinals and finals I
thought that was a bit of a weak point
especially that for instance in the last
preliminary round everything was was
done and over also sometimes the idea of
playing four games against the same
opponent is a good idea I mean I think
it's better than playing one classical
game I think much of follow forward
games is better to you know evaluate the
players form and the players shape of
course it was very exhausting I
I was always fitting
so need to ask at the end of a playing
day but other than that I mean I've
played badly but but I've emptied yes
and everyone was very much interested
pretty much when someone plays d4
against you everyone is expecting we're
gonna see a groom filled with at least
the one of the Knights of being on the
edge of the board
but now you've employed the Slav defense
here is that to avoid your preparation
for the candidate or was it just a spur
of the moment to maybe have some fun I
thought I thought it was a good time to
test out new openings
now I've I've been wondering for a long
time out on how to explain my repertoire
and of course I jumped up that much time
until now because my schedule was was
just frantic so especially in 2019 so
now you know there's some official
tournaments but this is that our online
but with the top player so I thought
it's very good test form for new
openings and yeah
overall I'm very happy ah I tried it out
yeah so immediately after that you had
one day rest and then immediately the
the fidei says calm nations cup started
with you again took part in so how was
that exhausting I mean playing from one
such big tournament immediately to the
other at this time being a team event
yeah no because I didn't qualify to the
semifinals and finals I had job like for
five days oh yeah it was better to
address but but yeah it was again a very
interesting experiment of course having
Gary as team captain was also I mean not
a burden but like we had to you feel
just pressure to pretty well yes exactly
we've we felt like we were the duty to
perform well
the other we didn't manage to qualify
but it was about a half a point margin
yeah yeah yeah we we've had tough fights
and in general we were we were fighting
for a good point so I mean I'm proud of
the way way we behaved and of course we
we me start so that's always unfortunate
but yeah I was favourably with
experience and so you know with having
Gary as team captain to remind us of our
blenders at the end of the games but
also [ __ ] good moves and engine Aliza
teams two periods I mean of course there
was no actual team union except on on
skype but yeah everyone was done to
fight for for each other so I think that
was cool yeah yeah that was one of the
things I wanted to ask how was Gary as
captain so all the best
yeah I mean well he maintains the level
of sorry I I'm missing the word okay one
second use French use fridge yes
existence but requirements okay yeah he
maintains the level of requirements that
that he asked for from himself
for his whole career so that's fine
because if it was you know less
demanding with him Sampson with others
then it wouldn't work but as as I know
is very romantic with himself of course
even his right to to ask the best from
from his players he's in it to win it
whatever he does exactly yes and since
you also mentioned the the simultaneous
exhibition you won 22 games I believe
drew yeah 22 last one
yeah and it's I've made a video on your
game against even new [ __ ] which read
on you yeah you invited him personally
to play and under Simon and like so many
of the comments were there's no way he
played that game he used an engine
there's no way someone can play like
that and I don't know if you if you had
the time or the opportunity to check out
the game yeah I mean first of all of
course on the internet there's always
gonna be this type of reaction so it's
you know it's our - to ignore them but
sometimes it's best I mean I don't see
any reason to suspect that that even was
using an engine and it would surprise me
very much for me I mean I don't and I've
been following him as a tennis player
and you know I think when you observed
level of competitiveness you
you also don't feel like I mean the
point of using an engine why yeah why
would it come to his mind
yeah I don't think so I mean I think the
game was pretty normal
maybe if I was a bit lucky with some
moves it didn't ring the tempters and c6
yeah yeah yeah so that happens but
otherwise his moves were pretty logical
and you know I also I don't know it's
true level so I've not played it and he
was against museum so I don't know our
life here is that he plays that well but
in general is fun moves that a lot of
players could find I mean you it feel
you had a very good day at the office
and you know I and helium yeah unless we
prove me that there was indeed cheating
I mean I see now the reason to
congratulate him on a very good game
which actually I thought so
already but yeah really I mean ice-t
like the chances it cheated if I want to
give a number would be less than 5%
yeah
stress so yeah but of course like I
cannot give proof racket it's always the
form you cannot give proof that someone
cheated or didn't cheat so but I don't
see the point in discussing that I think
it was a fun game I think it very well
and okay
no I'm asking because I was falling yeah
no it just burns me out such people are
you know so it's almost a week I'll see
if - good nice good sporting performance
like I mean everything is possible like
ID not everything but you know you don't
have to to be defiant on on every reason
that is achieved I think yeah but it
almost borders on jealousy I think also
yeah okay so that's that's basically it
regarding for the moment online online
chess and what everyone pretty much well
I've asked people to send me some
questions that they help me prepare and
like aside from the questions how do I
become a master of night or like the the
next the most popular topic is the
candidates tournament 2020 which I
imagine you were expecting so here I
found on your website in VHS calm which
is actually extremely detailed I found a
post you've published on March 8th 2018
you've said next Saturday March 10 all
eyes from the chess planet will be on
Berlin where the 2018 candidates
tournament takes place maybe I feel
maybe I will feel a little heartache as
I myself missed the qualification so
narrowly but it's only a matter of time
and so on so this time you've also
missed the qualification by just a
little bit of fraction in the World Cup
tour a job oh and then regarding the the
highest average rating also only to
answer yeah yeah yeah so how was how's
that I mean the second heartache that I
didn't see you publish anything
regarding this one yeah well first of
all
course I mean I don't know what I would
have posted like if the candidates
tournament that started without me but
when it started I actually wasn't sure
so this was a bit different but yeah not
qualifying was extremely painful
obviously and because I mean I knew I I
had I had a full right to you know to
compete in that in that tournament I
mean I had I had I mean in terms of
chess chance I had a full ride to to be
fighting to be a challenger of - and
yeah it was very painful to miss out
every time due to you know combinations
of like of you know stamina of course I
mean 2090 not be very exhausting and I
finished the season like in Jerusalem in
border lying in a burnout yeah just
physical burnouts and of course also I
mean some could say luck was lack of
luck wasn't saying involved because for
instance prior to the Grand Prix series
I expected that another score 15 points
was extremely likely to qualify for the
candidates
that was my estimation and I still think
it was a right estimation I finished
with 16 points and didn't qualify so so
well I am actually good results it just
I just wasn't rushed because of you know
again combination of maybe not being
able to pull my level - good enough
level that all other factors wouldn't
matter so like I fail to do
of course Cavanaugh managed to do in
2018 and dink managing I mean come on in
2017 and zinc in 2019 to be good enough
that nothing else I mean no no no lack
of luck no nothing could affect their
qualification for other players it was
quite a mesh to tooth and nails so I've
seen could happen and that was not the
only one of course as young we could
tell we could complain about missing
gotham in the level of of the players
nowadays is so is so good that that just
just yeah a lot of players at that they
could achieve a good that they have they
have a spot in the candidates just not
granted and now at the well now it's
adjourned mid half so it needs to be
continued about you and your anaconda
are leading the tournament so also what
I want to know is that morning when you
woke up and you received that email from
feeder asking you would you would you
maybe enjoy taking part in this
candidates tournament 2020 how fast did
you accept their their offer yes so the
thing was I was coming back from early
day so I was very dark in that sense at
you know I I actually took this time in
early 2020 I mean I played in Japan top
but in the vacation type of mind just
trying to twist my brain from another
excess of chess and excess of games that
had a real impact on my career so like
in that sense the end of 2019 was so
frantic in that sense that you know I
mean nobody else
and players who played like for instance
game winning candidates in the candy day
so of course what championship match is
add tougher schedules and I add is One
World Cup semi-finals
a lot of graham creeds and wenches to
finance and so open a lot of events and
no none of this is M could be used as a
as a West to prepare for city for the
next one or everyone under one a lot of
importance and so yeah 2020 was just
about about wasting I or so I thought
and so I I went on a vacation in New
York so of course in nine sites maybe
that was not the same thing to do but we
we didn't have enough information and an
takuna virus since the Cup in nineteen
to technically the correct decisions at
the time so I went there I have a fun
time with my friends and so I came back
to France and then when I'm on in the
taxi to come back to my place I receive
this message on Facebook saying that
hypothetically it's possible that a spot
opens up so my first reaction was
basically to just say yes and then I
called so first my manager to so that he
could get in touch if needed with the
organizers to work out details in the
case that it was confirmed that that
exported Frida and my my chest gosh its
young so that it could be ready at a
moment's notice to get computers our
computers up-to-date and also the
testing to
of seconds to so that they could work
full-time for two weeks and then of
course during the tune of minutes but
also the two weeks before the candidates
touch it less than two weeks because I
wish if that mr. Jones force of March
and the tournament started on the 17th
so yeah less than two weeks was there's
an idea of course to to prepare and to
and to you know make sure that there was
no gaping hole in my in my openings but
over given the timings elite I cooked a
lot of pressure on my opponents with
white and managed to survive with black
so in general yeah I mean they've done
an amazing job in the in this time span
and so on I'm grateful to them I mean to
everyone who's up me and I'm grateful to
myself for so far you know I think this
fresh state of mind and which friends
that I could I could be excited by the
opportunity fully excited and I played
my best chess in in at least four years
I think mm-hmm and do you think it maybe
also pose the problem for your opponents
in the candidates that well you didn't
have all that much time to prepare but
they didn't have all that much time to
prepare for you know I think the way it
works that they were prepared
I mean they were prepared generally on
the opening so they were ready to to
play more less against anyone of course
surely I was at the theoretical
disadvantage here but but the one thing
is that especially maybe for the
favorites
it's always difficult to cope with an
element of surprise and there were a lot
of elements of surprise of course it was
the situation with virus which meant
that of course it was difficult for some
of us to get to the actual location it
was
some additional mental strength I think
[ __ ] are the couple of flights
canceled instance before witching
Yekaterinburg and I was also one element
of surprise and of course in that sense
I think it's harder to cope with the
element of surprise that actually
preparing for from my opening sad at
least that was my assessment did you
find it odd when when a job of declined
to take part in the candidates
tournament due to will the current
situation yeah I think I think everyone
was was willing to take part but clearly
as it was there were some things that of
course were worrying for every player
it's just strange that that time or
didn't like try to connect with those
appears I mean it's difficult or so
because at the same time they're
competitors but clearly some some
players expressed discomfort and it's
like clearly at the same time fit I try
to organize fit area and of course yoga
knives in Yucatan would try to organize
it as best as they could given the
circumstances and there were a lot of
things to do but if fearful players come
come to the organizers and say we don't
feel we really don't feel comfortable I
think it's but we think it's better to
postpone it and clearly they were more
than than one sort of voice so this was
maybe this was one of the reasons that
the tournament was not postponed that
you know if players were discomfort they
didn't manage to express it in in a
singular way apart Co not coordinated
way yes exactly and do you think people
have been guessing will
the tournament finally continues is
there any possibility for raja baath to
actually take part in the tournament
like I've seen some ideas that let him
play a game against everyone so he also
played the first part of the double
round-robin and then the tournament just
continues with nine players and that's
that's only one of the ideas that I've
seen so do you think it's in any way
possible
yeah I mean there's a lot of options
that's not up to me to decide obviously
yeah of course but yes you're a giclee
it could be like possible to work out at
the same time of course like it's
difficult to to weigh in especially from
my point of view it's difficult to give
ya an unbiased opinion but yeah when you
give up your spot it's it's difficult to
to get it back and especially not at the
tournament of started it's difficult to
to get Tama back in the tournament in in
the way that make it that makes it fair
yeah like for instance if he has to play
a game against everyone that's not fair
to him because well he has to come to
play seven extra games to prefer seven
extra games would prepare me for one
that's kind of really difficult because
the base so like I mean from my point of
view I mean I cannot interfere with this
process I think it's up to two to demo
and feeder two to see if they can work
out some sort of agreement or maybe or
maybe they cannot I mean but but it's
not up to me to decide but fairly in
iron site is is decision to you know
abandon me spots was justified we just
didn't have enough information at the
time because clearly all of the failure
states did travel so so you know it's at
some point it's a - yeah of course does
everything and that's for feeded to
figure out yeah
and I've always found it interesting for
that this pretty much anyone what your
thought what are your thoughts in
general about the way the eight
participants are chosen for the
candidates so you have one that is
former vulture championship challenger
being Caruana
one being the highest average rating
that's uh nigiri then you have the two
qualifiers of the World Cup two
qualifiers of the feeder Grand Prix one
one one qualifier of the feeder Grand
Swiss and do you think do you agree with
those criteria I think I think there's
actually too many criterias yeah yeah so
of course I mean if I had to remove one
one thing it would be employ which is a
wild card I think I think the
qualification is tough enough for
everyone that she would just cannot give
one free spots even with with quite I
mean with straight criterias because
there are a lot of players who have been
missing out and juiciest candidates I'm
thinking about level of course I'm
thinking if I were the Baggio but you
cannot really merge their circuit
kayaking there's vision and there's some
shaft mamedyarov so so it's difficult to
just give this one spot almost for free
to the organizer when you know it's it's
only eight players it's a chance of a
lifetime for for most of the players so
I think it really has no business
existing and then the problem was and
for instance I think the grand feast was
an interesting experience
but I think it has an element of flood
that makes it unsuitable to pick only
one player so like I mean this year for
instance we were lucky that actual
winner of the tournament was qualified
but if Magnus or Fabian had one since
the qualifier would have been the second
or even the third place and that could
definitely be decided on type by
criterias that you know below 2700
player let's say no but that's not the
issue is saying if basically if you play
ten times the same tournament I mean
there's gonna be like if we just count
Magnus and maybe fab you know there's
going to be ten different winners
basically so he feels like an improper
way to to qualify someone I think what
was done in the history turns on/off
switch sometimes were these big opens
were like three or even five players
qualified to the actual candidates and
then there's not a lot more fights and
also one big advantage like in the last
front everyone's fighting for one of
these three or five spots in the
stoppers and there's no situation where
one of the players is fighting for the
top spot and his opponent is not yeah it
was definitely more interesting yeah so
I think and I think like this way you
know with this with these different
criterias it was all done to a bit of
luck like it didn't emphasize too much
stability and one of the thing is of
course the weighting average that was
just mathematically wrong because if you
up in the waiting on the first
February of the year then you have a
much higher chance to qualify than if
you if you'll get if you're having a
good year let's say you start with 27 70
you finish the year with 2790 that's
worse than starting the year with 2010
90 and fishing finishing the US Winston
70 or even like concern is the problem
in it being the highest average rating
or is the the rating criteria in general
no no the plumies when you start the so
yeah Iowa tips like also February and
March are not busy years busy month so
basically you keep you waiting and so if
you like 20 points hours and someone
well basically you keep these 20 points
and then if even if you lose 15 points
you're still higher than that person so
you keep higher waiting so you keep an
advantage on your average rating despite
having the worst here because you lost
let's say three games and you your
competitor didn't lose any so is that
the better reason you but she was still
ahead of him and though extreme cases
where it just doesn't make sense so
sorry I meant at the at the time that
the candidates were chosen you were you
were I think high rated an onigiri right
by small margin maybe I mean it was just
like no we basically have the same year
in terms of classical games we are the
more is the same performance so as a
year but the thing was in in September
he was already guaranteed to be IOH
economy despite not having the batteries
on me yeah and what we have and okay so
basically the
yeah was yeah so the World Cup is very
tough event and it's very difficult to
make it to the finals I know that from
experience but generally a lot of times
we see the same players of course use
ifs in 11 we need twice you think you've
seen dink
which reaching the finals twice in over
so Peter Svidler
has been wailing it and making it to the
finals
a lot of times so there's this element
of stability that doesn't come with with
a grand face and of course the Grand
Prix is very stable
by definition because of course it's
it's race really even subsequent
experience of course you can have gone
really bad event but you still keep
chances like young di by losing in the
first front in one and women's trousers
yeah and the so basically out of eight
spots that feed a grants the the
opportunity to play in the candidates
you can win five the other three are
basically you cannot really win them
like for instance Fabiana karana who was
the world championship challenger he can
basically get sleep for two years and he
will still play in the candidates
tournament yeah well I mean yeah it
feels numbers of the last challenger is
granted or I mean so that's four
champion in case of course the
Challenger wins the match which has not
happened recently feels no part that he
gets us but since the candidates to two
twice like of course he doesn't get to
be much an immediate rematch but he gets
a chance to okay so basically to make up
a bad sound yes so I'm final not suggest
that you know just that made for like
five qualifying events that were
scheduled to play in if we want you to
qualify so speak on trade one World Cup
and one grantees event and I have to
skip the ones with event for calendar
wisdoms so
to keep to keep fresh was the last
country so that was one the one thing I
one of the thing I have to say I didn't
like about the system of adding too many
events and then suddenly you cannot you
cannot fight for your chances in every
of these events because I would have
been lucky of course to play in the
country if it it had been like possible
to you know to play not coming back from
one month fighting Huntsman Sisk so
basically the one the one thing everyone
agrees and pretty much is that the wild
card needs to go well I'm not sure that
it won't with some some people are think
that one card is a good thing to find
out the registers and they have a point
but but on others I mean in terms of
sporting narrative coursers it has
simply zero business being okay so
existent Lee the wild card would make
more sense if it was a 12 players
instead of eight well even then no I
think the World Cup system
exists for instance in tennis it's like
you get you organized a Grand Slam event
you get like four or five well cards
maybe bit more but among 128 players and
so chess world cup is probably working
the same I think of six organizers well
maybe organizers World Cups and thinks
650 World Cup so that's like ten world
cards over over 120 players that seems
fair and that could up you know for
instance giving spot to a player who
should actually have business being
there or you know can help some young
players to to get the chance that at
this level of competition but here's the
candidates is just too special I think
you're you're basically coming to fight
for for the spots and yeah I think you
need
to have qualified for it because it's
nice players event and yeah and the
winner is gonna play against well as it
is Magnus so hey I think you you need to
have qualified in it just proven you
your skills okay so now after seven
rounds you are with Jana Polynesia
leading the tournament this is the
closest you've ever been to challenging
the world champions by final by far yes
and do you do Oh already sometimes
imagine it yourself challenging him for
the title I'm more than to her so like
so I was not worse when we started the
competition because we knew artists I
knew it could it could be aborted at any
moment given the situation and it turned
out to be what it when's Buddhists
closed in Russia
and so here yeah I mean I know that I
have one mission to accomplish first and
then if I went to candy dice and of
course I'll be putting every source I
have in doing it when the competition
resumes then I'll be thinking about the
match or not prepare and of course to
make myself ready for for the big clash
and also what's the difference for
example everyone in the world has a
negative result in classical chess
against Americans aside from neighbor I
will leave he still a favorite in that
one but what's the difference I think
you have like eight wins two losses and
18 draws against even class and closest
the wins yeah yeah okay so what's yeah
what's the main difference and it's
pretty much the same with everyone
except Napa so what's uh what's the main
difference when you face him then when
you face anyone else well it's just been
number one for so long that he is simply
a better player in general that doesn't
mean I cannot fight him
that doesn't mean that if I'm playing
the one championship match against him
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna paint for
four we to win it of course I will but
he's being the most consistent so one
play always makes fewer mistakes
obviously last ten years
so although that counts for something
it's a bit more recent but now is
probably the best player in the planet
and this way he manages to put everyone
problems I mean two sexes to set
problems to everyone change the games of
course like on occasions it's very
possible to fight against him and yes
obviously some weak points but yeah
overall he has more stability than
others yes more he has managed to
positive one more forums and users so
this way it gets better results in
tournaments and this way he collects a
good score against everyone so yeah it's
just not knowing he is the stronger
player as of now and is it do you forget
more excited when you play him then you
play somewhere else well it depends I
think for me matter stuff it also a
matter of the tournament situation like
if I'm not playing for anything I will
maybe like the competitiveness to that
is required to face him but yeah
otherwise it's of course a big challenge
and you need to come with this with a
strong attitude that you know you you
have a chance against him because
because if you don't he will curse you
so you have to come with attention of
winning it okay
and well not regarding so much the
candidates but it kind of leads to it
from the candidates what's your what's
your thought on deciding the world chess
champion like do you think it should the
title should be decided in classical
time format or are you okay with going
to rapid and blitz and let's hope not
even let's say world champion being
decided in an Armageddon game well I
mean historically of course it's been
it's been matches but Magnus admit as
makes a suggestion to to make it mix
like you know you placed you a lot of
days of classical just control and then
there are some days where you play this
much is so like I think that's also his
idea when he created is Magnus
Invitational like two places for games
of 15 minutes and I think that that's
one of his ideas that you know you can
play like one one day with 16 games
please I don't know and one day with
four web games or maybe two days and you
play still like twelve twelve days of
classical games I think maybe this is a
way to to avoid the actual time backs
and you know in general I think everyone
is from the top is ready to play some
good place and repeat games I mean for
instance Fabiano has been pointed out as
a weak web player and now is been MVP of
the last Nations Cup and of saw was they
trust qualifying to the finals it weeks
ago in Magnus invitation also everyone
is very capable of ending it and another
suggestion I think and in the actual
World Championship I think there's every
day every three days so like you play
two games you have a free
they'd like to get you every day I think
that's just too many free days like that
lowers the experience for for spectators
because you know you play two games you
have to wait and then when it comes to
the you know breaking point so you have
to give them you have two more games to
decide with the winner some know it's
going to be 14 games but at the moment
you have 12 games so then games okay you
will be winning to see some fights then
you have a free day it's okay so you
come back as the spectators you see game
11 and okay let's say it's even there's
a win and you know the last one is the
most win then what happens you have
another free diamonds at us I don't
think that works simply and I think in
terms of I mean it's also salsa would be
a better test of stamina of the players
if they unless we die so let's say one
free day if we four games with us every
five days I mean that's doing a lot of
free days but it works so we'll test
those coming out some players better
yeah but then it's not so much the
classical world chess championship it's
more of the general World Chess
Championships there's like it measures
everything yeah no but that's that was
one point and I think that was an
interesting idea I mean I'm not saying
to adopt it on notes I don't have that
power
I'm just thinking it's not it's not a
bad idea in itself but the other point I
was making about free days is definitely
not sports like changing time controls
it just in general is there should be
less few days for the for the spectators
and also to tester so players better and
that way you know I mean it's not about
making the players tired to get them to
make more endures because I still think
like one Wednesday we if we if we four
days every five days is basically what
we have at every tournament of course
there's much more stake and make much
more nerves but yourself much you are
much more
prepared because you've been preparing
for the last six months you have a team
of three to four players working
full-time to help you so I think you
should be ready to cover three days and
I think it would be a really good
improvement yeah and it's a much better
for the spectators which makes it more
enjoyable which makes it easier to find
sponsors and and and everything yeah
also it's like you can cover more games
in as much time so it's easier of course
for firstly organizers to justify it to
the organizers and to actually organize
it okay so and you also mentioned that I
also saw it today on Twitter that the
Magnus invitation was only just the
first of the five legs of the $1,000,000
beast that is the the Magnus Carlsen
chest or I've seen the the lineup for
the lintel Endora sabi has been
announced you are skipping this
tournament yes yes that's correct
I mean I was not invited that's fair
because I haven't performed well in the
last one in the Magnus Invitational but
obviously I'm I'm looking forward to get
another chance and I will probably get
another one in the third or fourth
tournament I don't know yet but yeah I'm
looking forward to to get another chance
and hopefully do perform much better
this time I've seen one of them it says
tres Legends is the name of the
tournament is it supposed to be like to
invite elite players plus some of the
chest legends
yeah I have no idea like it's it's not
my torso yes
so I'm not in charge of the invitations
so but yeah it would be fun for instance
if we could see could see Vladimir for
instance was recently retired but what's
been playing still quite strong in web
feed and boots because finish certain
thrusts its World Championship okay so
that's pretty much it regarding the the
candidates tournament and the World
Chess Championship cycle so where where
heading into some some general chest
questions and the the part that I'm
looking forward to the most and I think
the what the pub communities as well
to learn a little bit more about you as
a as a person not so much as a chess
player so here's an interesting question
like now and let's say twenty years ago
what's the difference between time spent
studying and time spent playing twenty
years ago and let's say now what's
what's the main difference it's odd for
me to say in the sense that I grew up
with computers of course but when I
became really really strong
already it was clear that you needed
computers to work you're on your
openings and basically full-time so I
missed that says the old days where you
were working with the chess board in
your pocket and an awesome position with
your second or so I did at that
experience of thanks but well yeah not
not on the daily basis on the daily
basis I'm on my computer and looking for
some lines of course my chest education
when I was young was not about openings
I mean of course I was studying openings
but clearly not to the level of accuracy
and depth that I am now so I was first
going myself as a player so of course
tactics tactics is basically the only
thing you you keep as part of your
training training weapons when you're
when you're an elite player just because
you need to keep in shape to keep
calculate your calculation because
otherwise if you just look as a computer
all day
it can soften your your brain and you
can lose your ability to calculate
deeply but all the theoretical end games
at
strategic on weapons a strategical play
middlegame our general concepts and so
on so done when you're going there's a
chess player so let's say between the
age of well from the moment you start
teams the moment you become a really
good Grandmaster basically I mean
there's that's not to say they're still
not musings to run so like if I'm coming
of course some some nice end game of
course I will like to study there was
this recent game between Leda and
stockfish I think this you know be show
at the Bishop movie yeah yeah that was a
bit crazy so you know there's always of
course new things to them but but this
other particle chess player of course
most of my time is now is now focused on
opening so I would say like 90% openings
and maybe nine percent would be on
tactics and at the time it was like like
when I was a teenager let's say it was
like 20 to 30% openings 40% middle game
and games 20% tactics and and so on like
and so yeah there's a lot of and now of
course the preparation this this is
talking about the preparation for the
actual chess preparation but there's of
course physical preparation mental
preparations that you need to to take
care of to to be able to to have the
best tummy now and the best so having
the best physical conditions to choose
the actual tournaments so you say you're
spending 90% of your time on openings so
how do you react or basically what is
your thought process when in the Magnus
invitational Carson played that Bishop
c4 move against
well is it really an ID or if if we go
by ship to see for what's your thought
process then I don't know if you've seen
the move before probably and I am not
seeing the move before I mean it was a
fan experiment it's not quite good but
it was a fun experiment and the idea is
quite nice that you then get back to
Milwaukee and the I didn't react best to
it so I could get that's one of Magnus
strengths a manages to set new problems
to his opponent because of course not so
instance one thing I don't like about
the chess world is that you know when
you when you an elite player you
basically like playing each other in
every tournament talking for instance
about Grantchester I don't like that you
know the secret is so close to two new
players two new young players and you
know the five shots you know I've been
playing against Magnus Forester hundred
games by now and same with also players
like West I saw like like unleash like
Levin like Fabiano I mean I've played
hundred games with at least fifty two
hundred games with each one of them I
think it's not it's not great because
then you're losing also the ability to
surprise your openers a little bit but
Magnus does it best in the sense that he
manages to come up in general with new
concepts against everyone but did it did
it ever cross your mind when after using
it against you Magnus also used it
against neppo and never accepted the
challenge and then yeah it's got a fella
part did it cross your mind that maybe
it would have happened if you accepted
it I have no idea like its ultimate to
make these kind of traditions but of
course he - differently pushed it Sunday
yeah okay and I'm interested in
okay now how can can everyone or anyone
for that matter let's say become a super
Grandmaster
for example Bobby Fischer he said
something in the in the sense that
genius is 2% talent and 98% work was it
like that with you or I'm not true like
it's hard to say I think of course you
cannot become analytical master without
without some time to begin with I think
it's just impossible but and I think
everyone from the elite is very talented
from the start and you know there's no
there's no one who suddenly started to
work eight hours a day and suddenly
became an elegant master I mean before
that they all were we all were very very
good players to begin with maybe we we
shop and you know our training schedule
but but who were the best in all
categories you know eight categories who
were we work when master I mean maybe
not for Bishop because he was he's older
than me so maybe it was I mean II I
don't remember at which age he became
calm a stir but no basically if you're
not you can master by by fourteen it's
gonna be very well for you to break
[ __ ] elite I mean the exception I can
think of his eleven but he was always
very talented to begin with so I think
talent definitely plays a huge role into
becoming a top and master I think you
can I mean with no talent at all I mean
you can work as as hard as you want
you're not gonna you're not gonna make
it but if you if you have some talent
and some understanding maybe not as big
you can definitely make it to one master
level if you put the necessary hours and
unnecessary and not only the necessary
hours but do it efficiently of course
right
you you cannot just say I work for for
five hours I'm chance I should improve
no it doesn't work exactly - to find the
correct areas to find the correct code
sheets and so on - to Italy and let's
say in the top elite I some okay maybe
the the 2700 club who is in your opinion
the most interesting chess player to
watch his games LaVon is very
interesting to watch in general a it was
maybe more true like in mid-2010 but he
was almost the best prepare and the one
who was always coming up with very
creative and interesting ideas so that
God is Games special flavour to follow
from the start to the fit to the end and
there were a lot of interesting moments
in these games but like Magnus games of
course to try to watch in general
Fabiano's games I mean there's a lot of
competition but when when I'm playing in
a tournament I'm always enjoying when
it's not my move to play - just have a
look at team supports and watch how
everyone is doing and maybe be happy if
I if I find some some ideas or so so
yeah but flavum is the one name that I
came naturally with yeah and do you also
do also enjoy it when you're playing a
game and the other players are checking
out your position yeah I find we focused
on my games so like if I'm thinking I
buy a zero too little attention to my
surroundings but sometimes it happens
that it's mind to play and suddenly I'm
bothered by something it's not those
affairs but by some noises this can
happen but of course I try to remediate
to as little as I can
so in general everyone is welcome to
watch my game
I'm not going to be disturbed by it or
change my focus and currently you're
most known for your for your night open
for your groom field what attracted you
in these openings that specialize in
them well I learned them from my
childhood
I mean basically from my early teenage
years and there were a lot of disbalance
imbalances so that was fun and this is
what I'm looking for so when you're
black you have two possible strategies
as an edit player and you know that Troy
is a very good result against everyone
in the elite unless your circumstance is
forcing you to place a Dorcas for a win
basically you'd be I mean I'd be happy
to you know to go to a game if I'm blood
and if I know that you know now I'm
gonna make a drawing I know it's not
quite for spectators and did you know it
doesn't happen because white has more
ambitions and that fortunately but you
know if white really wants to make a
door there's nothing I can do so you
come you come with the edges at twice
the good with up so there are two ways
you can achieve it so either you're
gonna play some solid opening who can
accept a slightly worse position
generally you you don't have my chances
in winning the game or you can try to
create some of these imbalances and
there's more risk we're up to it so for
instance in the night off if we
inaccuracy you make could be a losing
mistake compared to for instance of
Berlin in to Berlin you make one in a
Christian or is not gonna cost you the
game in the night off or in the garage
it could happen but at the same time if
white really wants full-blooded fights
and to get realistic chances to win
years to
to our country chances and this way and
I have not been that successful in
recent years with that approach in
sequential but in the light of I keep on
winning some nice games and this way
[Music]
this way you give you you opponent as to
put himself at risk if he wants to win
and this way you you do take more risk
but you're so of chances to to get a
full point at the end of the day and
since pretty much people know you're
gonna go for one of the two openings if
they go d4 reef or do they still manage
to surprise you or do you still out
prepare them well it depends of course
because there's a lot of lines to cover
it's it often happens of course that I
don't remember the exact details and but
then what sir fool is of course I have
good feelings for the position so it is
a Wakita from a memory or from my
instincts from someone but of course
always moments where your opponent is
out preparing you together with my team
and with the chen we try to to keep it
down to a minimum but of course at some
point it's up to me or two to be able to
to find the critical lines to avoid to
avoid being too much into being
surprised and maybe to surprise my
opponents into the openings okay and one
of one other thing i really enjoy is a
blindfold chess I don't do it all that
much myself but we'd say I can play one
game and maybe against maybe 1,500
player I will most likely win a game
against a 1500 player but there are of
course since Morphy played let's say
three or four opponents simultaneously
then you have to Margaret who I believe
played 48 opponents simultaneously yeah
I don't know if that records been broken
or it's still horribly not but I mean do
you sometimes play it what I mean
playing blindfold is just something that
comes naturally I've never played
simultaneous I mean blind for ten years
so I have no idea how many boards I
couldn't but what I think is that you
know at some point when I mean there was
this middle GM but when I mentioned
Monaco where there was some blindfold
section and also at some point I had an
experience bringing in a blindfold event
in the world mind games in China 2011 or
something and I thought that was really
nice
it's extremely challenging competitive
game of playing for much more than you
know just being with a friend and
placing that moves from your playing but
here you know again is the way you add
this sense of responsibility when you
play an actual move when okay the way it
worked was on a computer sitting in
front of each other and we were playing
some moves on the board but you know
every move could be costly and there was
a game I think I got that can skip
blundered he thought he thought like
Black Swan was I mean I don't remember
the exact detail but like he probably
saw Black Swan was on h6 you play Gucci
six check and there comes H Tex G series
and instant result so you know you have
to focus on every little detail and I
think that's that's and I think and I
was a bit sad that there's not been
enough
blindfold even since in the recent years
I think also in amber rapid I think
Karpov blunder the Queen to unit Bolger
no of course printers are very likely to
happen there was one one case where I
was very lucky because like I said my
book was on f8 he turned out to be on en
so I try to play with f8 x f2 and didn't
but I am NOT like blunder to peace in
the process just to be aiming for such
xf2 so I mean this sort of blender of
movements when you forget the actual
board append but but I think that's part
of the challenge I think it's good to to
challenge ourselves of course a blind 40
tournament is much more challenging and
Sun basically anything else I think if
you play a
3yp blind from games it's gonna be a
love difficult day but but I think
that's fine I think it would be fun for
and spectacular for the audience and
also was quite amazing is that we do
keep coming apart from see it's the
occasional blunder we keep a very very
decent level of chess I had one game
against even shakoora well firstly we
calculated like but ten moves long line
very very quickly and you know was I was
extremely impressed someday and tell me
when you close your eyes do you can you
see the board like really clearly or how
do you visualize it for example when I
try and play it sometimes I don't
remember what the board actually looks
like so I have to replay the moves and
then I have the position but like you
can do it instantly it's just there yeah
sometimes it's part of my thinking
process so I I mean I sometimes close my
eyes like mostly I will just look away
from the chess board so from for
instance to the ceiling and then just to
get a grasp in my brain of the actual
position to to implants of pieces on my
way on my brain and then I can start
moving some pieces in my brain and this
way I have more focus when I'm
calculating deep lines and then of
course I come back to the
physical chess but for verification but
it does happen that occasionally this
disabilities realization process in your
brain is more efficient and some
actually looking at the chess board okay
and regarding preparing those openings
that you've mentioned that you spent 90%
of your time on how do you use like a
general engine like stock which do you
use new neural net a is likely lecture
zero do you have what I use a mix of the
engines basically every every engine has
strengths and weaknesses of course Leela
was a game changer but but my
preparation doesn't consist exclusively
of Leela but it's been very well for in
some areas and regarding the strength of
your computer do you have like a really
powerful PC or you have at maybe access
to a supercomputer or you have to say
sorry about that when you do that sorry
about that
wait okay sorry very sorry about that so
now I see what what I look like
yes victory so what was I am yeah I just
forgot to plug into my computer
rookie mistake so question was sorry
yeah we were talking about opening so I
was do you have like yes your or maybe I
have heard some grandmasters actually
have access to supercomputers for
such a greedy shop was saying in a
recent interview that he was only
working with a laptop until he hired
Etienne with my coach as the second
cousin candidates by then I was already
and not using a laptop and clearly you
need the workstation to to make your
engine more efficient of course when it
comes to leave a you need powerful
graphic cards and so on and this way of
what you can be more efficient but
you're working on a laptop is at least
for elite players an obsolete way of
pairing yeah you'll have to wait like 10
minutes or so for to get to the bottom
of things
No ten minutes is what you have to wait
when your workstation if you are if you
only laptop you're probably gonna need
three to four hours okay then yeah
Sascha definitely has a lot of time well
no is that what you were saying he was
always getting out prepared by this
moves and he was spending a lot of times
on these openings but you know he sucked
for a moment his opponents were just
tweeting with it - brilliant and then he
realized they got some extra that he
didn't tough and person but he he made
up for that yeah and you've represented
France in the Olympiad I believe seven
times here
yeah from 2006
oh yeah and now is it official that
future is joining the French team that
he will be playing for France or is that
still not official but I still not
officially I think in its first to get
French citizenship it would be exciting
of course if it turns out that in future
French times are wax and Enya
I'm out people happy to welcome him to
adoration how big of a boost would it be
for the 40 French team
well depending on getting the right
atmosphere and white conditions to play
I think like it's very big contribution
because I could be it could be a top
scorer I could work well you know to
fight against the elite so yeah like you
know I remember there was another in
theater I think Vladimir was one of his
first Olympiad Kramnik swear I was done
for three or four and scored like agent
of out of nine so I mean I mean we're
not asking for that but that's the kind
of performance that that's totally
corruption that could that could happen
with future when his ways on when he's
on good shape yeah it could happen maybe
maybe even 909 who knows but you said
you've missed basically that part where
you go through the books you set up the
position from the books of the board
that you are a computer generation have
you had any any role models from the
past from the chess world when you were
growing up yeah mosfilm was impressed by
Fischer which is interesting life
stories the games were quite amazing to
study and this style was was very it was
very nice - very enjoyable and yeah I
think I ran a lot from studying his
games
I mean not only his games obviously I
mean I studied others but but he it was
a chess inspiration you know yeah and
also I've heard many many chess players
have certain rituals before big games do
you have any any weird ritual
before we're going to a game or is it
just sleep at and and play again no I
don't have we shown in itself I just
have a routine so like for instance in
the candidates I was waking ups ok going
to play first then watching some TV show
and so on and then like 1 hour before
the game you start remembering your
lines to be able to to play them and
remember them so you you work them out
for like 45 minutes alright and yeah I
mean I was just trying to have to have
also some music - so we fresh my mind
before going to the games generally I
get I have one song that I keep for for
the tournaments that I I mean I will
listen to other songs but I will add
this one songs that I will listen just
before going to the game but apart from
that I don't have wish and the song has
to change English into a mess okay it's
not I hope the tiger is it no it's never
been I of the tiger okay and you're some
do you have any thoughts on for example
Armageddon and the way to decide
outcomes were using Armageddon and the
which do you prefer
playing black or white and yes strangely
enough I've not been performing to worry
Nava didn't but I mean I think at some
point you have to to get a tie-break
between the players and if you get I got
some points in two World Cups that were
you would come to see I'm a given only
after five sets of blitz games and there
was one match in the first one that was
between a Cobian and trigger buff about
a group of that lasted until 1:00 in the
morning and since then
we've been more realistic and you know
for instance my much with Levin's that
came to zero Megiddo was already a six
hours much so that's with the
intensities that we had been providing
and of course the things at stake it was
actually a very very good quality much
and at some point you have to type like
the prior to putting zip tie and
Armageddon is a is the most efficient
way to to break it maybe not the most
fair but you've had like six hours to to
get the tiebreak so that's fine
I mean I think you know it's okay to to
make it on to one game as to black and
white
I guess rationally you should take black
but at the end of such a match so a lot
of things coming to your mind so like if
you've set your problems you open and a
lot of problems with white you're likely
to be quite if you get the chance but I
think if we wanted to some sort of sort
to sort out the correct up control tool
to make the chances even between white
and black then you wouldn't just need a
computer and simulate simulated games as
many as you can and then you would start
getting with good idea I think yeah the
fact especially that says increments of
the move sixty works in favor of black
at the moment but okay so you've started
your chest journey since you were when
you were four years old is that correct
again you're five I so I don't words of
chess when I was five yeah I think I've
also read on your website that you've
got a chess set for Christmas and that
that's basically when you've started and
I I do recommend everyone to check it
out there are a lot of cool stuff there
also a nice photo of Maxine when he was
like three years old and for four years
old and five very yeah very detailed
website
but when in your life did you really
feel that this was your calling or maybe
maybe you don't feel it your calling
maybe you were still looking into
something else no I mean food just isn't
that's been a huge part of my life for
the last 25 years but yeah it's come
just naturally so yes when we add this
chest that were familiar with chests at
them I'm just the one who ended up
choosing it's a must for Christmas I
just started playing game so it was a
natural chess set so you could you know
type on square I think he won was
easiest mud and so I would play one game
a day until I bet this Monday night and
I remember it was a very first game so
only one and then on the next day I won
and then I won on the next 24 days at
least
and so step-by-step I improved I did
start to improve quite a lot I mean of
course there was a book so that I was
reading and then we went to Chester by
Adam actual chess coach and started and
the thing is I kept the passion so I was
still always done for this game always
done two sorts of tactics to some
position always up here when I see some
nice ideas just what so and I think
that's true for everyone in theory if
you lose the passion you lose your you
lose your to trends you lose your you
ability to keep your focus because
because if you if you lose you're into
your basic interests then what's the
point in even playing and for instance
that's why for instance even cook and
fish have been a very good for so long
and in they're passionate about chess
and even so they've started it at tender
age and Aniyah is for even true for
instance chess has been his life of
course I was coach now or so
been an edit player until almost the age
of 70 and even Stanley was still done to
some pretty good fights I think in bed
Fabiano when he was almost 18 years old
so or 80 so so yeah quite impressive
I mean you especially see beating
Fabiana when you're 80 I mean that's
just out of this world but so yeah if
you're not passionate you're not you're
not gonna make it at least to the very
top and yeah keeping the passion is what
maybe keeps occurring and if one day I
lose the passion I know I will my days
will be counted as a chess box yeah and
you've gotten from around 2150 rating to
over 2700 over the range of some maybe
seven years so which part was the most
difficult for you to cross well there
were a few moments where you know you
feel like you'll be stagnating but as
long as I kept the focus and started to
work some things out it went better but
of course the absolutely most
challenging thing was to to break it
into the elite because you I mean I was
a 2700 or close to procedure hundred
since 2008 but then to actually make it
to the top ten it took me six years
maybe because I didn't have the right
training gabbi's maybe because I didn't
come in in the right state of mind or
maybe because I was just not doing some
things right and then you know you if
you have some tough events you start to
adjust and then do better and with the
games and the chances you get you get
more experience and at some point I
finally working to the top and and I've
been in the top ten for the past five
years now so I'm actually quite proud of
us
so you're saying that that actually took
you a long time from 2700 to top 10
that's not a reasonable amount of time
well it depends I mean sometimes you're
just not gonna make it any time in your
life and for some players like Magnus
it's you probably went from 2100 to top
them in in less in a year or so so you
know is there's no but of course not
everyone is Magnus Sifu phobia took him
to use for deep live and I think it took
him five years so you know it depends it
depends on the players I mean I don't
have the actual figure for favorite
player so but that's the way I remember
it
and you've mentioned playing against
your mother that the first game you lost
is that your first memory regarding
chest that you remember um well son yes
because his actual first game I played
no but it didn't it didn't like stick in
my brain and for instance like when I
started playing competitive chess so it
was this qualifiers you know first to
first regionals and then you have to I
mean like there's departments and with
juniors and then the actual win
championship and the right and so I was
just starting so I barely qualified both
times to the I mean first to the
regionals and then to the French
championship I barely barely made it I
finished third in the first competitions
and shared surgeons seconds I think
or maybe shared fourth and then I
qualified and then I won almost
effortlessly you know I was like a
complete newcomer to the French essence
and I I wanted so maybe that's my first
big memory so when I won that first win
championship and in since then I've been
the leader in my age category in France
and before Sanders
okay there's the then the first happy
memory yeah and I also do I've heard
that a lot of elite players meditate
have you ever tried meditating not truly
now meditating it's just not something
I'm good at
basically I don't have the patience to
to do it yeah I've never tried myself
but I've heard that no I know it's it's
a powerful tool for some persons but it
has to be for the right persons like I
know jokowi two instances he's using it
I think is also doing it but I'm just
not in the state of mind of meditating
so so for me it would be contradicting
my fear and also you have a you have a
bachelor's degree in math is that is
that correct well thank you exciting
bachelor degrees for use but in France
it's three years so in the equivalent
but just a bit less so if let's say you
were not because that alesis infants if
you were not playing chess full time
would you be doing something that's
regarding milady
yeah probably I mean I just decided to
to keep my academic studies going out
for a bit further just because I had
this luxury of being able to do so to
still keep keep a competitive level in
chess tournaments and and learn some
things of course keep some social
contact also with people outside of
chess so I thought it was nice
and of course mass with the subjects
that interested me and still interest me
so it's very proper person for instance
and when I end my chess career I will
come back to that math button as a pure
hobby theory yeah and so yeah so clearly
other not been involved in chess we
probably have I've tried to investigate
math mathematics a bit further
and is there perhaps anything you've
learned in math that can relate to
something in chess for example did it
help you with anything interest mmm
technically no I think I mean I take it
as two different subjects simply and I
know from experience that some players
not ask it in math and the other ones
some mathematicians are just not that
skilled in chess but of course there's a
are some you know comparisons you could
make that you know there's this need for
for logic and uniform with logical
reasoning so like you know you you take
it step by step and you try to break it
down to place a puzzle down in in math
or the colander
to try to solve it and the same when you
when you're working on the tactic you do
it one line at a time and so on and
until you you come up with a solution so
there are some similar which is curly
but but it's not like you can learn math
to get better chess that's not the way
it works yeah not what I meant I meant
maybe something to relate with it but
yeah it's interesting definitely and a
lot of a lot of parents are interested
in how to approach the training of their
children how to approach chess in
general so for example what advice would
you give to a young Maxime if if you
were starting over
yeah well first of all you have to get
the white coach
I mean you very well you can make it
without a coach and you just to be
someone of course who's a child you know
we'll appreciate as a human being and
it's just a way work so you need some
sort of connection then
of course like the chess coach must
probably be good enough at leasts and to
start to be able to you know grab the
kid out - to really guide him and also
like it's possible to guide a complete
beginner using some shortcuts but then
detrimental to his development in the
later years so I think it's good to have
some when fundamentals that are covered
properly from the starts so that you
don't get bad habits as a chip as a
child and then I think someone was
fundamental thing is you know like chess
is a wonderful wonderful game that I've
been playing up today for 25 years but
not everyone's the same and if a child
you know like lags just but at some
point wants to do something else or
maybe just doesn't enjoy it is a game at
all you know it's not necessary to push
him to the limit like it makes a kid
plays a game if he enjoys it if he wants
it but if he doesn't you it's
counterproductive so it's better to yeah
like everything else yeah like
everything else exactly so like I'm you
know Anya coaching people to to teach
their son or daughter chest and to you
know if they want to get point to it to
get some code to give them some some
good boys and so on to start to to to
learn the game properly and maybe think
playing competitively but only if they
want it basically yeah okay so I've also
read on your website that your
kind of a sports fan it says that at a
younger age you were a big fan of the I
don't know if I can pronounce it a
Olympique Lyonnais is it yes that's
correct
and also that you're a big fan of Roger
Federer so are there any other sports
you enjoyed not only following but maybe
do you partake in any sports I like I
like sports I like playing sports in
general I'm just they look at it but
from chess but I like a good game of
tennis once in a while and yeah but
forms items for following Morris if we
start with the exception of swimming
every sport with the exception of
swimming like yeah sonic finger will
follow Snuka with follow curling
athletics curling I've been watching
some kinds of coding definitely a sports
fan okay definitely darts darts okay
who's the who's the best in darts is
from Calvin I meant Michael Franco
like is there a country in general
that's really good oh well I mean it's
really popular in England you know you
rating the pubs
yeah that's what I would say Irish buddy
okay maybe yeah same thing okay so I'm
not gonna take too much of your time but
I will ask you a few more questions yeah
animal person yes or no no no no like if
you see a dog on the street you're not
going to go pet it nobody not I mean I'm
not gonna torture them of course not but
yeah no I have no attraction towards the
web steps okay okay and regarding
personal life is there is there any
girlfriend involved maybe I don't know
if there's a wife at least I don't yeah
not not at the moment
okay and how important would it be to
you that
your future lets a girlfriend or wife is
at least interested interest not so much
that she has to play it no I think it's
two different things like the advantages
and disadvantages of you know of my my
girlfriend if she plays chess or not
there are some differences and some some
things are good different is some things
are bad so you know I've already just
like it just depends like um I don't
have a preference not not in the
slightest that is fighters yeah it's not
like no girls are under eighteen hundred
yellow it's not like that not okay no
and also it says on your Instagram
profile it says a very brief description
of yourself it says chess player games
junkie so what what are the some of the
games that you enjoy I play a lot of
card games recently I've been playing
too much poker for my own good but as
these French card games of call tower
of course I enjoyed the occasional game
of darts board games as well and you
know a good game on the computer on the
PlayStation and so on yeah basically and
of course last but not least a very good
game of chess yeah that's okay it goes
without saying and any specific games on
on computer or PlayStation it's been a
big fan of Warcraft then of course
football games I've not yet started
fortnight's but maybe for my for my own
good as for board games I don't know
like I've played Catan quite a lot and
I've started other games like for
instance if we Maurice every Saturday
night we meet with some friends would
play some board games
[Music]
like doing the log dance away we gonna
zoom we onion and we start playing some
games
I think someone mentioned you're a big
fan of what's it called is it Avalon
yeah as well yeah yeah okay I have not
played it for some time now but yeah it
was a good game we played it first time
in no way doing no HS so Magnus watch it
and then we all started getting the hang
of it so we are playing Morris every
night in sync it was 2016 and the level
lost being evil okay yeah I think I've
played a similar game but I think it was
a the evil guy with Hitler and you had
to figure out who yeah but I think it's
pretty much the same thing but yeah the
same idea yeah but it's it requires a
lot of sneaky tactics so it's a you know
it would appeal to chess players I
imagine yeah no it's definitely a fun
thing and also eight you know in a way
it's more social like for instance the
life between CLE Chester's we've not
talked about it but there's a lot of
mutual respect engine or so there's
really except for maybe a few exceptions
no animosity between the chess players
so like we're not friends I don't think
so at least so like but we have enough
respect to you know to get along well
and to be able to take off fights to the
chessboard
but in between that will be a thing like
normal gentleman to watch each other at
least that's my policy
yeah well okay a lot of like doing some
of the online events now I think it was
doing the Magnus invitational there was
this they asked everyone this question
like would you take to the deserted
island or who would you be in quarantine
with and everyone shows you like you're
a super guy to be around with who do you
take with you I don't know I mean I
would choose I don't know like I have
sweet pea
players I would probably take after
picking business would be our choice
between 11 Fabian Sasha
Fabian Sasha okay yeah and what do you
think pretty much everyone chose you I
don't know you should ask them but I
feel a bit flattered okay maybe I will
and okay last in the life section from
the top of your head any any favorite TV
shows movies yeah I mean lifetime would
be Breaking Bad okay and then I don't
know if fringe was also a very good one
and then in western times of course
better course ah but that's a follow-up
to Breaking Bad and there's been one
I've been enjoying quite a lot recently
but yeah but more much more TV shows and
movies scary yeah I think it's like that
with everyone now with the Netflix and
everything it's just and not everyone
but I just fall asleep doing movies
don't ask me why I don't know but I just
posted the last movie you fell asleep -
I mean I've not watched a movie in like
in like two years so I actually fell
asleep in the in the cinema during
Sherlock Holmes with Robert Downey jr.
no but okay to give an idea of the
extent of my sleepiness during movies I
fell asleep doing so doing one of the
soul
okay that's yeah okay movies are not for
you and here we have the last part of
our well this conversation and I've
enjoyed it immensely are some of the
questions from my subscribers they are
very short very short question so it's
basically a yes or no but I thought that
it would be interesting to include
so here we go number one your favorite
tournament win probably the same field
cup 2017 because it was the first really
big one and that's when you consider
favorite okay
the favorite game you've ever won mmm
I would say probably the game against
more savage 2009 right I know a lot of
work yeah yeah yeah they call it like
the the Maximus or something like that
it i and but is there is there like a
favorite game that you've lost um not
anymore
yeah yeah now you just enjoy winning yes
okay is there any particular most
memorable move that you've played yeah
think well of course this is for cage 7
against most image but I'm not so I
thinking about this concept against
England because there's something I
found by myself I mean got to move by
computers with this 93 King dito ideas
closing 2013 so I gave up one pole and
Kass of my king in a move 8 and then
locked down all his pieces on the Kings
side and one with his concept like what
was actually a very cool game and they
were enjoyable artists from my side yeah
I don't think I've seen it but I will
check it out
yeah I wasn't yelling do you have a do
you have a have you had a favorite field
in math doing during your studies um
earth metics
I was kind of fun but or you know
complex analysis and was it feels like
topology also it feels really quick
service okay but there with matrix
my arithmetic so Kay do you have do you
have any let's say a childhood dream
that you've always wanted to to fulfill
I mean if you like don't worse you're
really down to earth so no engine area
no big dreams okay
okay this is one how many games do you
know by heart I don't even know my own
games by heart so so very few maybe a
hundred like the classics be yeah we're
just not even knowing some by heart I
mean I will know because of course I if
I see a position I will most likely we
could nice again Nagisa a classic black
so but knowing it move by moved fairly
not mm-hmm okay sir
which player from the past would you
like to meet and play this is pretty
much an always question for any chess
player of this time no wait no of any
time of the past
yeah maybe burn time Bronstein any any
specific reason yeah I mean I've had
this books obviously and was they it was
very creative and a very interesting
person at least it felt like from from
waiting its books so yeah without love
to to know more about him well the 1953
steric tournament yeah but well this one
was nice but most pieces of socialism
apprentice which was much more detailed
as a biography okay but of course
there's week 53 worse server is a
milestone Mac you need to read it as a
chess player okay here's a here's a I
think a really fun question one of the
subscribers asked what was your first
thought when you met Antonio for the
first time yeah I've made I've missed
you in Zagreb yes
[Music]
yeah basically I was just so focused
with my with my legs with my game
because we were playing in the next five
minutes because of course when we come
to the game would come at the last
moment so I just mechanic face yes I
died and went my to my game yeah no not
official you know feelings about the 10
cutter yeah okay we basically just
ambushed you before before the game can
you can you describe yourself using
three words um I mean I am those three
words
I mean I'm it's a tough one huh no I'm
just looking for translation okay okay
yes I'm teasing I like to tease people
so much fun I am competitive but only in
chess in other compartments I'm not not
that much and I pretend to be funny
sometimes
okay at least that's what I would like
to be yeah okay I don't think I know the
word for that trying thinking that
you're funny but okay
teasing comparative and trying to be
funny
that seems like we figured out why
everyone would choose you for a deserted
island all right
beer or wine beer beer I know I'm French
but beer yeah everyone people even sent
me questions like which specific type of
wine you're doing but I kind of thought
you will be your man yeah I am
no just okay
no basically everyone I've tested tasted
I don't like it so much unless it's a
really good wine store like I'm nobody
I'm not that elitist but when it comes
to one I have to be my plate otherwise
doesn't doesn't stand it okay
yeah similar similar to my case are
there okay this is a good one
are there any good chest pickup lines I
have not I've not tried enough of them
you've not tried enough but you have
tried them from time to time yeah I it's
like it's the same with chest jokes have
you ever heard of a good chest joke no I
think it's a it's a legend yeah I mean
I've seen people try and but I've never
actually heard a good one
so still still in the search for that
one also here's an interesting one I
thought on the Evans gambit outdated by
hundred years hundred years but there's
still this game that in 1995 I believe
Kasparov defeated Anand with it yeah no
I mean I've played it a couple of times
in games but that doesn't mean it's a
good opening yeah so it's there sadly
it's not not even remotely appliable
what is not losing by force but yeah oh
there's another price weapon it doesn't
yeah okay fair enough
okay interesting one have you ever had a
dream involving chess probably but I
don't have a habit of remembering dreams
so but yeah I mean probably at some
point guitar problems yeah sometimes
when I have over like a really crazy
dream I'm like yeah I'm totally gonna
write it down because I'm gonna forget
it in the next five minutes and I never
do and I always forget it yeah I mean
that's not your first instincts on your
wake up yeah
okay here's a bit of a bit of a
philosophical one your greatest victory
and most crushing defeat but not
interest is there such a thing not truly
like I live I live my life by the
moments I think my victories are you
know spending good times with my family
and with friends I think spending this
kind of quality time is the most
important thing in in my life
okay fair enough and yeah I think I
think that's that's about it that we we
are we have reached the end I see that
you have some some issues with your
throat so sorry sorry it took so long I
imagine yeah thanks ok I just don't have
you did not have enough water but that's
fine yeah you have to always have one
prepared and while preparing for the
podcast since this is my first podcast
I've also learned that it's it's
customary
well maybe not customary but it's that I
should ask my guest is there anything I
should have asked you but but didn't I
think we recovered a lot of grants I
think it was fun and I don't have much
to add myself okay so nothing nothing to
add and also I've been asked by do you
know the artist hygge she makes it yes
yeah of course I know I've seen alive in
a few tournaments because at first she
came to cheap water and I didna well not
like from number of ciabatta but 10
years member and she also performed like
I seen in know which has a new songs I
think it was tactic Tao oh yeah well
basically she asked me to tell you that
she made a song for you and
it was supposed to be ready for today
for the podcast but it's not since the
editing is taking a bit longer but for
you dear viewers and listeners it will
be available in the description below so
you can check out the the Maxime song
it's basically I will definitely check
it out yeah okay so yeah there we have
it here you got your own song yeah and
yeah really really enjoyed it thank you
Maxine for your time thank you
we'll see maybe maybe we can do this
some other time maybe
by then you'll be a World Chess
Championship challenger who knows and
hopefully yeah let's hope that gradient
but as the viewers in this last two
hours but I think there were a lot of
interesting stuff we talked about so
yeah so it's all fully not everyone is
being it's been sleeping like I do
during movies yeah so it wasn't an
excruciating experience nah so nothing
like this so you're saying you would
recommend it to others to join the
podcast yeah my thing is I they should
try okay very nice and one of the
questions also for the end there was
asked by one of my subscribers is how
come you accepted the offer to come as
the first guest on the podcast you don't
really know what to expect
I've never done anything like this um
yeah when I saw it's like it's good
experience it's always nice to share you
your views and I feel like you know when
you're I feel like a sportsman in the
sense that you know when you I'm a lead
player you have some sort of moral or
ethical duty to you know the audience
the spectators to to be able to share
your thoughts with them to be able to
take a few moments may be doing
competitions if you know someone from
the audience is coming directly to a
tournament and once to engage with you
asking for an autograph or photo or just
you know making small talk I mean of
course like he you know laughs I don't
have time to speak with everyone
the planets but if you know someone is
interested enough in chest to to watch
YouTube videos to come to a tournament
to to watch my game to to ask me for a
photo I will do like every sportsman
that he expects himself and just and
just do it and that don't feel like it's
it's a pain I mean I feel like it's the
duty but I also feel like it's
interesting to it to engage with with
your audience
mm-hm okay that's it's very commendable
and I'm very happy that it's so so I'm
that's that's pretty much it for this
podcast once again Thank You Maxine for
for joining me and if you're not too
tired as we we've previously talked
about it we will play one blitz game
five minutes yes and but not life it
will be available for you in the
description below so the first thing you
will see in the description below is a
chess game analyzed by me the game
between me and Maxime did you prepare
for it intensively I did it for the last
two hours yeah that's that's what I
expected all right
so to check it out you know who knows
what could happen so once again thank
you Maxime I think everyone for watching
and listening and hopefully that's you
soon
you
[Music]